I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAM service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so cold, up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfil along the way, because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession.
我是Jo，在兰开夏郡的一家儿童与青少年心理健康服务（CAM）机构担任助理心理咨询师。在准备临床心理学培训申请时，我购买并阅读了Marianne的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。它成了我这段时间里非常好的陪伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它让我有机会沉浸在别人的故事中。它及时提醒我，不要只盯着最终目标而变得冷漠，要珍惜并享受我们一路走来的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都意义重大。它还让我确信，通往临床心理学的道路是多元的，这对我这样经历过曲折、而非典型职业路径的人来说非常重要。
I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared It's put evening tasks on hold for a while though, because once you've started reading, it's tough to put it down. Struggling with your thoughts, wondering why you feel stuck or how to finally move forwards. Cognitive behavioural therapy or CBT is one of the most widely researched and used therapies in the world today. But what actually happens in CBT and how does it help? Whether you're considering therapy, supporting someone else or training to be a psychologist
我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过要做好准备，它可能会让你暂时搁置晚上的任务，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。如果你正为自己的想法而挣扎，想知道为什么自己感到停滞不前，或者如何最终向前迈进，认知行为疗法（CBT）是当今世界上研究最广泛、使用最多的疗法之一。但CBT到底是怎么回事？它又是如何提供帮助的呢？无论你是在考虑接受治疗、支持他人，还是正在接受心理学家的培训，
yourself, this episode is for you. I'm chatting with Sahana, a qualified CBT therapist. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Please like and subscribe for more, and Sahana and I both hope you find it really useful. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne, and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm joined by my wonderful guest for today, Sahana. Hi, Sahana.
这一集都是为你准备的。我正在与合格的CBT治疗师Sahana聊天。我是Marianne博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容，Sahana和我希望你觉得这非常有帮助。嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我是Marianne博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我的精彩嘉宾Sahana也加入了我的行列。嗨，Sahana。
Hi, Marianne, thanks for having me. Thank you for being here, and you are here in your capacity. as a, both an aspiring site, but also a qualified CBT therapist, don't you? Yeah, it'll be interesting to talk about CBT in a different setting. Normally I'm used in like a therapy setting or work setting. So yeah, I'm very excited to share my thoughts. Perfect. And I know you'll do a brilliant job. So the aim of today for anyone watching is that we're going to think from a service user perspective
嗨，Marianne，谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你能来，你今天是以双重身份来的，既是一位有抱负的心理学家，也是一位合格的CBT治疗师，对吧？是的，在不同的环境下谈论CBT会很有趣。通常我习惯于在治疗环境或工作环境中使用它。所以，我很兴奋能分享我的想法。太棒了。我知道你会做得非常出色。所以今天对于任何收听的人来说，我们的目标是从服务使用者的角度
about what CBT is, kind of what it might be used for, and I guess a bit about what they can expect if they're understandably feeling maybe a bit nervous because they've received maybe a letter or an email through the post telling them that they've got their first CBT appointment and they're like, oh, oh, that's really normal, isn't it, to feel nervous about stuff
来思考什么是CBT，它可能用于什么，我想还有一点是关于如果他们感到有点紧张，他们可以期待什么，因为他们可能刚收到一封信或一封电子邮件，通知他们已经预约了第一次CBT，他们会想，哦，哦，对未曾做过的事情感到紧张，这真的很正常，不是吗？
that maybe you've not done before? Yeah, of course. I think CBT is quite well known, but I think a lot of people haven't actually tried it before. So yeah, getting that letter through the post and not knowing what it's about, is it going to be, you know, I've had clients say, you know, is it going to be beyond my control, you're going to read into my body language, so there are a lot of myths out there that would be helpful just to bust them, but yeah, it would be helpful to kind of clarify that a bit more today. Yeah, and obviously I know when I've worked in services for the NHS, sometimes we're offering services to people that actually find it really hard to leave the house because they might be feeling. really anxious and maybe even with something like social anxiety which CBT can be really useful for the idea of sitting kind of across from someone that can feel
是的，当然。我认为CBT相当出名，但我认为很多人实际上并没有尝试过。所以，收到那封信却不知道它是关于什么的，会是怎样呢？我有客户说，这会超出我的控制吗？你会解读我的肢体语言吗？所以外面有很多误区，如果能打破它们会很有帮助，但今天能稍微澄清一下确实会有帮助。是的，显然我知道当我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作时，有时我们为那些实际上发现很难离开家的人提供服务，因为他们可能感到非常焦虑，甚至可能患有社交焦虑症，而CBT对这种情况非常有用。那种坐在某人对面可能会感到
really difficult can't it yeah so I've always spoken to you Marianne about my social anxiety and actually CBT has personally helped me and I've always the equivalent I would draw in CBT when you have social anxiety is you know therapists were like you know you're scared of spiders but you know you're gonna sit there with a spider we're going to expose you to that so it's definitely nerve-wracking but there are ways to kind of work around it so since the pandemic obviously we've made therapy more accessible so I'm offering remote therapy but also across NHS as well that's an option out there and I think we we try to make it as accessible as it
非常困难，不是吗？是的，所以我一直和你谈论我的社交焦虑，实际上CBT对我个人有帮助。我总是会用CBT中的等价物来类比，当你患有社交焦虑时，治疗师会说，你知道你害怕蜘蛛，但你知道你会和一只蜘蛛坐在那里，我们要让你暴露在那种环境中。所以这绝对是令人紧张的，但有一些方法可以绕过它。所以自疫情以来，我们显然让治疗变得更容易获得，所以我提供远程治疗，但在NHS中这也是一种选择。我认为我们试图让它尽可能地
can be work around those barriers and that people might initially face when trying to access therapy. Amazing. So I guess if it feels insurmountable, maybe speak to the service and ask for maybe whether there's any accommodations that can be made. Oh 100%. So usually we would, what we would actually do is do an assessment to gauge kind of are there any practical barriers, any barriers when it comes to sort of their mental health, that could inhibit them from getting the help that they need and then to kind of cater towards that you know even um you know there's been a rise in being neurodivergent and then we actually
容易获得，绕过人们在尝试寻求治疗时最初可能面临的障碍。太棒了。所以我想如果这感觉不可逾越，也许可以和服务机构沟通，询问是否可以做出一些调整。哦，百分之百。所以通常我们会做的是进行评估，以衡量是否存在任何实际障碍，或者在心理健康方面是否存在任何可能阻碍他们获得所需帮助的障碍，然后去迎合这一点。甚至，你知道，神经多样性的人群在增加，所以我们实际上
at the start of the assessment ask are you neurodivergent or even if you're not diagnosed is there any adaptations we can make just to make therapy a bit more accessible so yeah definitely if there there's anything as always we might miss something so definitely do raise it with us or let them know because i do think the one thing that we would want is that honesty and rather than just suffering in silence. So yeah, a small call or a simple question can really help iron out things and make it a little bit more, I don't know, it's seamless to eat into a very difficult process. Exactly, because we want people to be set up to thrive and to do really well at this. We don't want them to be thinking that it's already outside their comfort zones. So tell us,
在评估开始时会问，你是神经多样性个体吗？或者即使你没有被诊断，我们是否可以做出任何调整，让治疗更容易获得？所以是的，如果有什么问题，就像往常一样，我们可能会遗漏一些东西，所以一定要向我们提出，或者让他们知道，因为我确实认为我们最想要的是诚实，而不是默默忍受。所以，一个小小的电话或一个简单的问题真的可以帮助解决问题，让一个非常困难的过程变得稍微无缝一些。没错，因为我们希望人们能够准备好茁壮成长，并做得非常好。我们不希望他们认为这已经超出了他们的舒适区。所以告诉我们，
CBT stands for cognitive behavioural therapy. But what is it? So if I was to describe it as like a one-liner, like a newspaper headliner, it's the relationship between your thoughts, feelings and your behaviours. So usually I'd like to explain why it's important to look at those three areas. And I'd like to show a bit of a cycle that kind of showcases those three areas. So when we talk about situations or how we feel, we usually say that a situation makes us feel some type of right? So we might say, I got really anxious at that party. But actually, if it is just that a situation makes us feel some type of way, then that same situation would have the same feeling
CBT代表认知行为疗法。但它是什么呢？如果我要用一句话来描述它，就像报纸的头条，它是你的想法、感受和行为之间的关系。所以通常我喜欢解释为什么审视这三个领域很重要。我喜欢展示一个循环，它展示了这三个领域。所以当我们谈论情况或我们的感受时，我们通常会说，一种情况让我们产生某种感觉，对吧？我们可能会说，我在那个聚会上变得非常焦虑。但实际上，如果仅仅是某种情况让我们产生某种感觉，那么同样的情况会对每个人产生同样的感受，
for every single person. And that's not the case. That's not what we find. So our emotions can vary in terms of its intensity, but also we might even have like complete different emotions. And what that really boils down to is the meaning we attach to those situations. So by meanings, we can call them our thoughts. You know, we might have mental images. We might have past memories that might come up, even if it's kind of related to an upcoming situation, but that really dictates how we feel. So if we have a look at this particular example, the thought is, I'll embarrass myself and, you know, one might feel slightly anxious. And that can have a knock on effect in terms of how we behave them. So we might be less inclined to go to that party.
而事实并非如此。我们发现的情况并非如此。所以我们的情绪在强度上可能会有所不同，而且我们甚至可能产生完全不同的情绪。这归根结底是我们赋予这些情况的意义。所谓的意义，我们可以称之为我们的想法。你知道，我们可能会有心理意象。我们可能会有过去的记忆浮现，即使它与即将发生的情况有关，但这确实决定了我们的感受。所以如果我们看看这个具体的例子，想法是，我会让自己出丑，然后，你知道，一个人可能会感到轻微的焦虑。这会对我们的行为产生连锁反应。所以我们可能不太愿意去参加那个聚会。
On a similar wavelength, if someone thinks I'm really excited, it's about big day, and then celebrate, that same situation party could be excitable, it can bring on emotions of joy, and then the behaviour would be completely different, so it'd be eager to go, eager to plan, set up. So these three components have a knock-on effect with each other and keep that cycle going, and cognitive behavioural therapy or CBT basically looks at breaking down those patterns. So by focusing on the behaviours or the thoughts, that would naturally have like a knock on effect on our emotions. And so if we shift our thoughts from, I'll embarrass myself to, well, let's see how it goes. We might be more open and curious as opposed to feeling quite anxious.
同样地，如果有人认为我真的很兴奋，这是一个大日子，然后去庆祝，同样的情况——聚会，可能会让人感到兴奋，带来快乐的情绪，然后行为会完全不同，所以会渴望去，渴望计划，准备。所以这三个组成部分相互影响，并保持那个循环。认知行为疗法或CBT基本上着眼于打破这些模式。因此，通过关注行为或想法，这自然会对我们的情绪产生连锁反应。所以如果我们把想法从“我会让自己出丑”转变为“好吧，看看会发生什么”，我们可能会变得更加开放和好奇，而不是感到非常焦虑。
Perfect. So nicely done. And I guess it might be useful for us to think about when we would intervene. So of course if we are feeling a little bit anxious about something, like maybe doing something like this today or before we went on camera, we were talking about something that I'm doing that's new and different, and you're like, do you feel nervous about that? And I was like, well, not in that particular instance, but often in this instance, I do. And it's absolutely fine to feel those feelings, especially if they are novel. But I think we're looking at when it becomes so that you aren't functional or so that your well-being is affected. So we're not aiming to kind of immunise people
太棒了。做得很好。我想我们思考何时进行干预可能会很有用。当然，如果我们对某事感到有点焦虑，比如今天做这样的事情，或者在我们上镜头之前，我们谈论了我正在做的一件新的、不同的事情，你问我，你对此感到紧张吗？我说，嗯，在那特定的情况下不会，但通常在这种情况下，我会。感到这些情绪是完全没问题的，特别是如果它们是新奇的。但我认为我们关注的是当它变得让你无法正常工作，或者你的幸福感受到影响时。所以我们的目标不是让人们
against normal emotions but it's when they're crippling or paralysing isn't it that we owe it to themselves to intervene or ourselves even absolutely so you know i'll embarrass myself might be it might be a very normal thought to have but again i think it lies down to the severity of how you might feel that way and the frequency as well um so as i've told you when um i went for CBT for social anxiety the level of impairment that I had, you know, I couldn't even order a restaurant. My best friend had to do it. You know, I couldn't talk. So it had such a restrictive impact on my life.
对正常情绪免疫，但当它们令人瘫痪或无法动弹时，我们有责任进行干预，甚至是对我们自己。绝对是这样，所以你知道，“我会让自己出丑”可能是一个非常正常的想法，但我认为这取决于你产生这种感觉的严重程度和频率。所以正如我告诉你的，当我因为社交焦虑去接受CBT时，我所受到的损害程度，你知道，我甚至无法在餐厅点餐。我最好的朋友不得不帮我做。你知道，我无法说话。所以它对我的生活产生了如此限制性的影响。
And that's when CBD can be really useful. So we're not trying to kind of abnormalize or kind of make scary of like everyday situations, everyday natural reactions, like feeling nerves or being nervous in a particular situation isn't a problem at all. It's when it starts having that ripple. and it's so intense and it's difficult to deal with. That's when CBT can be a really helpful intervention. I also think the nice thing about CBT is that its perspective is
这就是CBT非常有用的地方。所以我们并不是试图将日常情况、日常的自然反应变得不正常或可怕，比如在特定情况下感到紧张或焦虑根本不是问题。当它开始产生那种涟漪效应，并且非常强烈且难以处理时，那才是CBT可以成为非常有用的干预手段的时候。我也认为CBT的好处在于它的视角是
all of these sort of problems, if you'd call it, actually stem from really natural kind of emotions. So social anxiety, you know, we all have a natural tendency to want to be light, to be impressionable, you know, we're social creatures, we want to be accepted. but if it becomes kind of more pervasive and it controls various aspects of your life to sort of really great lens. So CBT can actually help people if they're feeling quite restricted and limited with their anxieties or low mood to live a richer quality life so that it doesn't have such pervasive control over them. Yeah, because everybody deserves to have a good shot at thriving
所有这些所谓的问题，实际上都源于非常自然的情绪。所以社交焦虑，你知道，我们都有想要被喜欢、给人留下深刻印象的自然倾向，你知道，我们是社会性动物，我们想要被接受。但如果它变得更加普遍，并且在很大程度上控制了你生活的各个方面，那么CBT实际上可以帮助那些感到焦虑或情绪低落而受到限制的人，过上更丰富的生活，这样它就不会对他们产生如此普遍的控制。是的，因为每个人都值得拥有茁壮成长的机会。
And actually from a variety of reasons, maybe from bullying or kind of the way that we've been raised or just the people that we find ourselves maybe working alongside, we can feel really undermined and that can get to us. Often, you know, we do the thing called formulation, don't we? We make sense. So if we're using like a longitudinal formulation, we look at what might have contributed to this, like what we think about as the precipitating factors, don't we? Could you tell us a little bit more about that? yeah so CBT really banks on that so it looks out what keeps the problem going so it has a very much here and now focus so I might tell my clients you know if you fell down the stairs and now you're afraid of walking down the stairs just because you know you knew how you fell down the stairs doesn't necessarily mean that will get rid of the problem we need to look look at what's
实际上，出于各种原因，也许是因为欺凌，或者我们被抚养长大的方式，或者仅仅是我们发现自己与之共事的人，我们可能会感到非常受挫，这会影响到我们。通常，你知道，我们做一种叫做“个案概念化”（formulation）的事情，不是吗？我们理清思路。所以如果我们使用纵向的个案概念化，我们会看看是什么导致了这种情况，比如我们认为的诱发因素，不是吗？你能多告诉我们一点吗？是的，所以CBT确实依赖于此，它着眼于是什么让问题持续存在，所以它非常关注“此时此地”。所以我可能会告诉我的客户，你知道，如果你从楼梯上摔下来，现在你害怕走下楼梯，仅仅因为你知道你是怎么摔下来的，并不一定意味着这就能解决问题。我们需要看看是什么
keeping the problem going so what might have set it off might not carry on it might look very different now, the actual problem. So within the context of, so when we say, when you mention formulation, Marian, what I show there is like a silly tool version, like a very simplified version, but it kind of looks out, what keeps the problem going, you know?
让问题持续存在。所以最初引发它的原因可能不会持续下去，现在的实际问题看起来可能非常不同。所以，Marian，当你提到个案概念化时，我展示的是一个简单的工具版本，一个非常简化的版本，但它着眼于是什么让问题持续存在，你知道吗？
Is it the thoughts? Is it the behaviors? And that's largely down to working together with the client, with full consent and knowledge. I'm just asking them and exploring that problem in it detailed analysis i suppose so that way once we've identified okay so these are the things that keeps the problem going we can then look at what can we do to kind of manage them and not let that
是想法吗？是行为吗？这很大程度上取决于与客户的合作，在完全知情和同意的情况下。我只是在询问他们，并以详细的分析探索那个问题，我想。这样一旦我们确定了，好的，这些就是让问题持续存在的事情，我们就可以看看我们能做些什么来管理它们，而不让它
interfere our lives so much so we can dismantle that cycle basically amazing and is this going to be like a super heavy thing for clients to do in between sessions because often actually clients do want own work or homework so that they can practice some of these skills. What are people likely to be sent away with or asked to do? Yeah, I think in the earlier sessions, the therapist usually takes the lead with the between session exercises or homework or, as you would say, own work, which I've started using now. What it would usually involve is collecting data, that's what I'd call it. So have a go at this week. Just see how you're getting on, drop down some of the things that trigger.
干扰我们的生活太多，所以我们基本上可以拆解那个循环。太棒了。这对客户来说在两次会话之间会是一件非常沉重的事情吗？因为通常客户确实想要“自己的工作”或家庭作业，这样他们就可以练习其中的一些技能。人们可能会被要求带走什么或被要求做什么？是的，我认为在早期的会话中，治疗师通常会主导会话间的练习或家庭作业，或者正如你现在所说的“自己的工作”，我现在也开始这样用了。它通常涉及收集数据，这就是我所说的。所以这周试一试。看看你进展如何，记下一些触发
your cycle. And that can really help us to really reinforce, is this the problem that we're actually working on? And that's really important during the early stages, because one of the underpinnings of CBT is that we want to have a problem of focus. If we spread ourselves too thinly, we might not have any real benefits. So if we have like an overarching problem and we're working towards that and we're kind of bringing our awareness skills to the table, you essentially become your own therapist, really, through that experience. and once you sort of then collect the data, then we then move on to kind of the intervention part where we would then give tools and techniques for them to try.
你循环的事情。这真的可以帮助我们真正强化，这就是我们正在处理的问题吗？这在早期阶段非常重要，因为CBT的基础之一是我们想要有一个焦点问题。如果我们分散精力，我们可能不会有任何真正的收益。所以如果我们有一个总体问题，我们正在朝着这个目标努力，并且我们正在运用我们的意识技能，你实际上通过那种体验成为了你自己的治疗师。一旦你收集了数据，我们就会进入干预部分，我们会给他们工具和技巧去尝试。
So there's quite a lot of between session exercises, and people don't really expect that, you know, when they, the first two sessions normally are spend time just assessing suitability for CBT with them. Does it meet their expectations? Because at the end of the day, we don't want people to feel like that they have to do something like a certain approach because they've been told to it's a very much a collaborative effort that you know CBT so we usually ask them how do you feel about homework or you know between session exercises is it daunting for you or is it not your cup of tea writing things down this is what
所以会话间的练习相当多，人们并没有真正预料到这一点，你知道，当他们……前两次会话通常花时间评估他们对CBT的适用性。它符合他们的期望吗？因为归根结底，我们不希望人们觉得他们必须做某种特定的方法，因为他们被告知要这样做。这在很大程度上是一种协作努力，你知道，CBT。所以我们通常会问他们，你对家庭作业或会话间的练习感觉如何？这对你来说是令人生畏的，还是说写下东西不是你的菜？这就是
CBT work looks like this is how it works so how do you feel about that so having those sorts of conversations is really important so that way we're on the same page and that collaborative tone is there from the get-go. Yeah, it's not something that's being done to you. It should be feeling like something that you're part of and we're kind of working with your window of tolerance. We don't want someone to be feeling over-aroused, under-aroused, so hyper-aroused, hypo-aroused,
CBT工作看起来的样子，这就是它的工作方式，所以你对此感觉如何？所以进行这些对话非常重要，这样我们就能达成共识，那种协作的基调从一开始就存在。是的，这不是强加给你的事情。它应该感觉像是你参与其中的事情，我们正在某种程度上配合你的“容纳之窗”（window of tolerance）。我们不希望有人感到过度唤醒或唤醒不足，也就是过度兴奋或兴奋不足，
so that they're not able to be functioning. And I guess, you know, with CBT often there'll be an element of kind of behavioral activation, doing something a bit different and kind of seeing how that goes. but what that is not, is not, it's not flooding, you know, so actually if social anxiety is what you're being seen for, you know, in between session one and two, the therapist should not be saying to you, right, go out and stand in the middle of, you know, Lester Square. Like, that's, that's not fair. That wouldn't be right. That wouldn't be okay. But what they might say is,
以至于他们无法正常工作。我想，你知道，CBT通常会有行为激活的成分，做一些稍微不同的事情，看看效果如何。但那不是，不是，不是“洪水疗法”（flooding），你知道，所以实际上如果你因为社交焦虑而就诊，你知道，在第一次和第二次会话之间，治疗师不应该对你说，好吧，去站在莱斯特广场的中间。那，那不公平。那是不对的。那是不可以的。但他们可能会说，
could you maybe consider being in the background when the postman comes to the door and your partner answers it like we literally trying to break down on a scale almost of one to a hundred what would be step one and helping you to to manage yourself to to make changes I think that's the great thing about CBT the fact that it's graded it's a gradual approach it's not kind of we're putting you into the deep end off you go let's see if you kind of manage but also the activities that they'll do is aligned with their values and we make sure that it's meaningful and important to them. So that way there is that motivation to do that, which is, yeah, I really feel held back when I'm in the staff room and I'm so anxious. I can't even talk to my colleagues.
你能不能考虑在邮递员来敲门而你的伴侣去开门时，你在背景中待着？我们实际上是在尝试分解，几乎是在一到一百的量表上，什么是第一步，帮助你管理自己，做出改变。我认为这就是CBT的伟大之处，它是一个分级的、渐进的方法，不是那种我们把你扔进深水区，然后让你自己去看看能不能应付。而且他们做的活动也与他们的价值观相一致，我们确保它对他们来说是有意义和重要的。所以这样就有动力去做，也就是，“是的，当我在员工休息室时，我真的感到被束缚住了，我太焦虑了。我甚至不能和同事说话。”
So we kind of gradually build sort of activities to work towards that point where they are able to do that specific situation. It can be quite empowering. I think most importantly, it's done together with the client. You know, we don't want to kind of, do activities where it's not challenging at all because then what are we really learning here? And I think that's very much the essence of CBT. We're sort of asking ourselves all the time, you know, myself as a therapist, I always ask, what did I learn about this session from you today? And what did you learn about this session from this session rather?
所以我们逐渐建立一些活动，朝着他们能够处理那种特定情况的点努力。这可能非常令人振奋。我认为最重要的是，它是与客户一起完成的。你知道，我们不想做那些根本没有挑战性的活动，因为那样我们到底学到了什么？我认为这在很大程度上是CBT的精髓。我们一直在问自己，你知道，作为治疗师，我总是问，今天从你那里学到了什么？或者说，从这次会话中你学到了什么？
So that generally that learning component is there underpinning all of this. So we want to make sure that the distress or the discomfort is there enough for them to kind of take away something from that experience so we're constantly like working like detectives really like testing out hypothesis and we're not literally holding magnifying glasses but we're looking at these thoughts with a magnifying glass metaphorically speaking and we think well is this true you know how likely is it can we find this out does it feel safe enough but albeit a bit uncomfortable and then we kind of roll with it and see how we get on all right
所以那个学习成分通常存在于这一切的基础之上。所以我们想确保痛苦或不适感足够让他们从那种体验中带走一些东西，所以我们不断地像侦探一样工作，测试假设。我们并不是真的拿着放大镜，但我们是在隐喻地用放大镜审视这些想法，我们想，嗯，这是真的吗？你知道，可能性有多大？我们能查出来吗？这感觉足够安全吗？尽管有点不舒服，然后我们顺其自然，看看进展如何。好吧。
So let's try and kind of get a sense of maybe an imaginary person with real problems that might benefit from CBT and how we do that. So if I pluck a random made-up person out of my head, Jay, he's 32. He has been cheated on by his partner and it's led to his mood really lowering. It's also led to him thinking like he's not good enough and, you know, that he's feeling lots of shame and everybody knew about this and have got things that they're saying about him and maybe his manliness,
所以让我们试着了解一个可能有真实问题并能从CBT中受益的虚构人物，以及我们如何做到这一点。所以如果我从脑海中挑出一个随机的虚构人物，Jay，他32岁。他被伴侣欺骗了，这导致他的情绪非常低落。这也导致他认为自己不够好，你知道，他感到非常羞耻，每个人都知道这件事，他们都在议论他，也许还有关于他的男子气概，
he wasn't enough to satisfy his partner. And he tried to go back on a dating website, but it was really crippling for him and led to him feeling really anxious, really self-critical. It's impacting on his work. He's feeling like he doesn't want to go to work because there's kind of people at work and they all know and it's, oh, you know, the referral comes in
他不足以满足他的伴侣。他试图回到一个约会网站，但这对他来说非常令人痛苦，导致他感到非常焦虑，非常自我批评。这影响了他的工作。他觉得他不想去上班，因为那里有人，他们都知道，而且，哦，你知道，转诊来了，
and it's all feeling too much. How could our treatment with Jay progress with CBT? I mean, there's a lot there, isn't there? And I think in the first two sessions, I like to just create a bit of like a problem list where they can kind of get it all in there. So that way, you know, we've kind of got the main problems, but also if there are any knock on effects, that's also on there.
一切都感觉太多了。我们如何用CBT来推进Jay的治疗？我的意思是，那里有很多东西，不是吗？我认为在前两次会话中，我喜欢创建一个问题列表，让他们可以把所有东西都放进去。这样，你知道，我们有了主要问题，但如果还有任何连锁反应，那也在上面。
So when you mention dating scene, that's a key trigger at a minute. but also it started off because of the relationship breakdown and perhaps there's some self doubts as well about how he sees himself or maybe some negative thoughts like for example I'm not good enough so we'll write that all down on a bit of a list and then we'll kind of cluster them you know are these problems relevant to each other are they linked to each other so then that makes a problem a little bit more manageable and actually we realize it's the same problem having a knock on effect and having these symptoms I suppose once we've identified the problem of focus and it could be anxiety we could specify that a bit more we don't have to do that at this
所以当你提到约会场景时，那是目前的一个关键触发点。但它也始于关系的破裂，也许还有一些关于他如何看待自己的自我怀疑，或者一些负面想法，例如“我不够好”。所以我们会把所有这些写在一个列表上，然后我们会对它们进行聚类，你知道，这些问题彼此相关吗？它们彼此联系吗？所以这使得问题稍微容易管理一些，实际上我们意识到这是同一个问题产生了连锁反应和这些症状。我想一旦我们确定了焦点问题，它可以是焦虑，我们可以稍微具体一点，我们不必在这一
stage but we could just label it as anxiety but then we also look at their goals for therapy does it align with that anxiety problem of focus so if they're saying i really want to become confident when I am out there going on dates or you know on dating apps you know I'd like to put myself forward for that and anxiety is what's stopping me from doing that so then we then we kind of coincide both and once we do that then what happens is we start building on that skill of awareness so this is the stage where I might take the lead a little bit more and I might say okay well let's find out what happens and how often it happens you know it can't just be dating scenes there must be more to this but that's okay you know often we're not aware so let's try and hone in on that skill
阶段这样做，但我们可以把它标记为焦虑。但我们也看看他们对治疗的目标，它与那个焦虑的焦点问题一致吗？如果他们说，我真的想在出去约会或在约会软件上时变得自信，你知道，我想让自己去尝试，而焦虑是阻止我这样做的原因，那么我们就把两者结合起来。一旦我们这样做，接下来发生的就是我们开始建立那种意识技能。这是我可能会多主导一点的阶段，我可能会说，好的，让我们找出发生了什么，以及它发生的频率。你知道，不可能只是约会场景，一定还有更多，但没关系，你知道，通常我们没有意识到，所以让我们试着从一开始就磨练那种意识技能。
of awareness from the get go I'm already kind of fostering that sense of agency to them you become your own therapist go out into the real world and find out what's going on because I don't know and I'm very open about that I don't know that's what you're here for you know you're the expert of your difficulties and I'm the expert of CBT so let's work together here so they'd go out and they'd bring back their data sheet of like a week's worth of triggers and that will then give us a great understanding of what are the areas that need to working on and what are some of the things that keeps the problem going and like i showed you the previous sort of cycle marian that's kind of what we'd draft up together and it's done together with the client it's
我已经在那培养那种代理感了。你成为你自己的治疗师，走进现实世界，找出发生了什么，因为我不知道，而且我对此非常坦诚。我不知道，这就是你来这里的原因，你知道，你是你困难的专家，而我是CBT的专家，所以让我们在这里合作。所以他们会出去，带回他们的一周触发因素数据表，那将给我们一个很好的理解，了解哪些领域需要努力，以及是什么让问题持续存在。就像我之前展示的那种循环，Marian，那基本上就是我们一起起草的东西，它是与客户一起完成的，
always everything every part of this is done with a client and I always ask the feedback I ask them does that make sense or have I went off the rails then usually it'd be like yeah no I I get that or they've add to that can I add a little bit more to that there's something else that's just come up now so we kind of build on that model and then we start looking at the intervention side of things so what do we need to look at working on or managing so if it is that there's intense avoidance, so they're not even on dating apps at all because they're thinking, I'm going to make a fool of myself, I'm going to overshare, or I feel ashamed, I don't know
总是，这一切的每一部分都是与客户一起完成的。我总是询问反馈，我问他们，这有意义吗？还是我偏离轨道了？通常他们会说，是的，不，我明白了，或者他们会补充说，我能再加一点吗？还有别的事情刚刚出现。所以我们在这个模型的基础上进行构建，然后我们开始关注干预方面。所以我们需要关注努力或管理什么？所以如果存在强烈的回避，他们甚至根本不在约会软件上，因为他们认为，我会让自己出丑，我会过度分享，或者我感到羞耻，我不知道
how to tell them about anything that's happened in my past. We look at managing those sort of negative automatic thoughts, we call them. And there's lots of different interventions, but we might look at that as a set intervention, give them some worksheets to work towards managing their thoughts. We're not trying to replace the thoughts of something positive, but just kind of bringing it back to more realism. And then that can have a knock on effect. So if they're thinking, I don't know how I'm going to cope, you know, I don't know if I can even tell them. I can never be myself with another person, a potential partner. We can, that might shift from that to actually, yes, I've had an awful experience in the past
如何告诉他们我过去发生的任何事情。我们着眼于管理那些所谓的“自动负面想法”。有很多不同的干预措施，但我们可能会将其视为一套干预措施，给他们一些工作表，朝着管理他们的想法努力。我们并不是试图用积极的东西取代这些想法，只是将其带回更多的现实主义。然后这会产生连锁反应。所以如果他们认为，我不知道我该如何应对，你知道，我不知道我是否甚至能告诉他们。我永远无法在另一个人、一个潜在伴侣面前做我自己。我们可以，这可能会从那种想法转变为，实际上，是的，我过去有过一段糟糕的经历，
and my brain is obviously on the lookout for that. But that doesn't mean it's always going to be that way. There are, maybe there are people out there that can understand me and it can take time. Over time, I can build that trust and open up to them about my relationship. So already the thoughts kind of shifted to something more grounded and balanced. And then their anxieties might be reduced. You know, might not completely go away.
我的大脑显然在寻找那个。但这并不意味着它总是会那样。也许外面有人能理解我，这需要时间。随着时间的推移，我可以建立那种信任，并向他们敞开心扉谈论我的关系。所以想法已经转变为更扎实和平衡的东西。然后他们的焦虑可能会减轻。你知道，可能不会完全消失。
But then that would then promote. It would then put enough doubts in those thoughts to then test them out now I always rely on skepticism if someone's like completely like no I'm not doing it then we kind of work on right what's going on here we need to improve we need to get a bit of flexibility there that you know or maybe there's a reason why about very valid reason why there's something that's not explored but if it's more that actually it's anxiety it's coming from the past and it's manifesting now jay might find that actually maybe i could give us a go yeah I feel really nervous but maybe I can install a dating app and just test
但这会促进。它会给那些想法带来足够的怀疑，从而去测试它们。现在我总是依赖怀疑论，如果有人完全像“不，我不做”，那么我们就会处理，好吧，这里发生了什么？我们需要改进，我们需要在那里获得一点灵活性，你知道，或者也许有一个原因，关于为什么有些东西没有被探索的非常正当的理由。但如果更多的是实际上它是焦虑，它来自过去，现在正在显现，Jay可能会发现，实际上也许我可以试一试。是的，我感到非常紧张，但也许我可以安装一个约会软件，只是测试
someone or swipe someone I'm interested in. So already there is a shift there isn't there from not being on dating apps at all, being engulfed by that fear to, well, let's just see how it goes. It's scary, but we can find out. Yeah, and I guess we want, we don't want him to forget that this has been really sad and that he wanted this to work out. But also, we want him to believe that he deserves to be in a relationship where if, you know, just being kind of monogamous is really important to him, that's someone that wants to treat him in that way with respect for what they've got together and that there is a possibility that can happen again in the future. Yeah, absolutely. I think CBT, although it focuses on the hearing now, if it is
某人，或者向我感兴趣的人滑动。所以已经有了一个转变，不是吗？从根本不在约会软件上，被那种恐惧所吞噬，到，好吧，让我们看看会发生什么。这很可怕，但我们可以找出答案。是的，我想我们希望，我们不希望他忘记这真的很悲伤，他希望这能成功。但我们也希望他相信，他值得拥有一段关系，如果，你知道，仅仅是保持一夫一妻制对他来说真的很重要，那是有人想以那种方式尊重他，尊重他们在一起拥有的东西，并且未来确实有可能再次发生这种情况。是的，绝对。我认为CBT，虽然它关注此时此地，但如果它
connected to a relevant past experience, I think it's really important to acknowledge that. It's obviously coming from a place, a place of hurt, a place of fear, even a place of trauma. So for Jay, that relationship, you know, it probably meant the world to him, hence why his brain is on that overdrive to protect him and not put him through any kind of that sort of situation again, right? And so it's really important to validate that place. So we're not sort of dismissing it and saying, well, focus on the hearing now and, you know, you'll be back to like how you were, but actually realising, you know, that's really devastating that you'd been through something like that. it's no wonder that you feel the way you do makes a lot of sense and then thinking about does it align with what you want you know how you are and and the way you're dealing with this and it really it's down to the individual really whether they're ready to kind of think
与相关的过去经历有关，我认为承认这一点非常重要。它显然来自一个地方，一个受伤的地方，一个恐惧的地方，甚至是一个创伤的地方。所以对于Jay来说，那段关系，你知道，它可能对他来说意味着整个世界，这就是为什么他的大脑处于那种超速状态来保护他，不再让他经历任何那种情况，对吧？所以验证那个地方非常重要。所以我们不是那种解雇它，说，好吧，关注此时此地，你知道，你会回到你以前的样子，而是实际上意识到，你知道，你经历过那样的事情真的很令人沮丧。难怪你会有这种感觉，这很有道理。然后思考它是否与你想要的相一致，你知道，你是怎样的，以及你处理这件事的方式。这真的归结为个人，他们是否准备好去思考
about doing something different it might be that you know in a complete different scenario Marianne if they're not ready and they're thinking I'm really really lost and this relationship has taken such a toll on me I don't even know where to start that's a person that really needs that time and space to process things and yeah but they might not be quite suitable for CB2 which we'll look we'll talk about a little bit more later but yeah it's really important to validate you know that's one of the fundamentals you to understand the person their story what have they been through, you know? What are their difficulties? Does it connect with the past? And kind of connect with that story and almost build that picture at the back of your mind, but also share it with
做一些不同的事情。可能在完全不同的情况下，Marian，如果他们没有准备好，他们认为，我真的非常迷茫，这段关系对我造成了如此大的伤害，我甚至不知道从哪里开始。那是一个真正需要时间和空间来处理事情的人，是的，但他们可能不太适合CBT，我们稍后会多谈一点。但是的，验证非常重要，你知道，这是基础之一，去理解那个人，他们的故事，他们经历了什么，你知道吗？他们的困难是什么？它与过去有关吗？并与那个故事建立联系，几乎在你的脑海中建立那幅图景，但也与
them as well. So you're on the same page as them at all times. Amazing. And I appreciate how long is a piece of string and different services are different. But what is maybe typical for what someone can expect for kind of number of sessions they might be offered for CBT? So I work at like an adult service at the minute. So it really does depend, like you said, on the service. So it can go up to 20 sessions. On average though, it's 12 sessions. So it really depends on the nature of the problem.
他们分享。所以你始终与他们保持一致。太棒了。我很欣赏“一根绳子有多长”（意指情况各异），不同的服务是不同的。但对于CBT，人们可以期待的会话次数通常是多少？所以我目前在一家成人服务机构工作。所以它确实取决于，就像你说的，服务。所以它可以多达20次会话。不过平均而言，是12次会话。所以它确实取决于问题的性质。
What we usually do to help facilitate that and to make sure it's not abruptly ending or you're not sure where it's headed. We do regular reviews. So I do like every four sessions, I do a bit of a check-in, how are we at, where we are, are you feeling is this something that fits your needs and sometimes you know CBT might not be it you know the structure might not work well for that individual so it's important to sort of catch it early and you know in the first couple of sessions when you explain these are the principles this is what's expected
我们通常做些什么来帮助促进这一点，并确保它不会突然结束，或者你不确定它要去向何方。我们进行定期审查。所以我每四次会话做一次检查，我们进展如何，我们在哪里，你感觉这是否适合你的需求？有时，你知道，CBT可能不是，你知道，这种结构可能对那个人不起作用。所以尽早发现这一点很重要，你知道，在最初的几次会话中，当你解释这些原则时，这就是所期望的，
does this fit your bill you know is this what you're looking for and I know actually I really don't like work cheese and that's that's for us to think about well what else can we look at but in general if you're happy with CBT we look at every four sessions or so, it just depends on the clinician really about, are we headed in the right direction or have we drifted? And does it require a bit more work? And then we might extend the sessions with justified reasons. Yeah, I guess we don't want this kind of video or podcast episode to put someone off. Like if they've already got it booked, it's much better to go along, try it. And then if you think it isn't working for you, talk to
这符合你的要求吗？你知道，这是你在寻找的吗？我知道实际上我真的不喜欢工作表，那是我们需要思考的，我们还能看什么？但总的来说，如果你对CBT满意，我们大约每四次会话看一次，这真的取决于临床医生，关于，我们是否朝着正确的方向前进，还是我们偏离了？这需要更多的工作吗？然后我们可能会在有正当理由的情况下延长会话。是的，我想我们不希望这种视频或播客剧集让某人望而却步。如果他们已经预约了，去参加、尝试一下要好得多。然后如果你认为它对你不起作用，和
the clinician about that because they might well be able to help make the right referral for the thing that might be the thing that works. So please don't just not turn up or just, you know, drop out. Like always talk to the person because that ultimately is going to help you to get where you're going to be having your needs best met, I think. Absolutely. I do think generally speaking, although, you know, as clinicians, you know, we strive to make sure that it's collaborative, you know, we're always constantly asking for feedback, aren't we marrying what asking, is this all right? Does this work for you? And it's not that we were in short, we just want to make sure that they're on the same page as us, really. But often what we
临床医生谈谈，因为他们很可能能够帮助做出正确的转诊，去寻找可能起作用的东西。所以请不要只是不出现，或者只是，你知道，中途退出。像往常一样与那个人交谈，因为我认为这最终将帮助你达到你的需求得到最好满足的地方。绝对。我确实认为总的来说，虽然，你知道，作为临床医生，你知道，我们努力确保它是协作的，你知道，我们总是不断地寻求反馈，不是吗，Marian，询问，这还好吗？这对你有用吗？并不是我们不确定，我们只是想确保他们与我们达成共识，真的。但通常我们
find is there is still this sort of air of the clinicians, the expert, you know, they know what they're talking about, you know, they're the one spearheading this. And if they, they know what they're doing and I should just follow Sue. It can't be further from that. That is so far from the truth. And actually, what would honestly help, and I always say this to my clients is, if there is a bit of you that feels like I don't really like this I don't even connect with a therapist let me know you know there's nothing personally taking that whatsoever just let me know I'd rather you let me know than struggle in silence because by being transparent you're kind of asserting your rights there aren't you which is this is really working for me I'd like to
发现仍然存在这种临床医生是专家的空气，你知道，他们知道他们在说什么，你知道，他们是带头的人。如果他们，他们知道他们在做什么，我应该跟随。这离事实太远了。这离事实太远了。实际上，真正会有帮助的是，我总是对我的客户说，如果有一部分你觉得我真的不喜欢这个，我甚至没有和治疗师建立联系，让我知道，你知道，这根本没有任何个人因素。只要让我知道，我宁愿你让我知道，也不愿你默默忍受，因为通过透明，你是在维护你的权利，不是吗？那就是，这对我真的有效，我想
explore other options or other pathways here and I just want to foster that a little bit more because I don't think that's done enough from my experience. I don't see a lot of that. Despite, you know, trying to kind of create that sort of environment, there is still that discrepancy of, well, the therapist knows, the clinician knows, I'm just going to follow and see where it goes. So, yeah, if we do ask, how are you feeling about this, how are you finding it? The best thing is to be transparent so we can kind of be on the same page.
探索其他选择或途径，我只是想稍微多鼓励一下，因为根据我的经验，这方面做得还不够。我没怎么看到过。尽管我们试图创造那种环境，但仍然存在一种差异，即：治疗师知道，临床医生知道，我只是跟随并看看会发生什么。所以，如果我们确实问“你对此感觉如何？你觉得怎么样？”，最好的做法是保持透明，这样我们才能达成共识。
Yeah, and when we're stretching and we're growing, actually, things might not always feel super comfortable, but they shouldn't feel so awful that it's painful or overwhelming. And it's making me think about when I'm doing personal training sessions with my lovely personal trainer. And sometimes even when I'm doing the exercise, I go, I'm going, hate it. Hate it. I'm really makes a laugh. But like, it doesn't mean that I don't want to do it. It's just actually, oh, this is, this is harder that I thought. And I know if I was by myself, I wouldn't do this. But because I'm with you, I feel safe. to do this and i know you'll keep me safe so it's it's okay to have a little bit of that
是的，当我们伸展和成长时，事情可能并不总是感觉非常舒适，但它们不应该感觉糟糕到痛苦或难以承受。这让我想起我和我可爱的私人教练进行个人训练的时候。有时即使我在做练习，我也会说，我讨厌它，我讨厌它。这真的让我发笑。但这并不意味着我不想做。只是，哦，这比我想象的要难。我知道如果是我自己，我不会这样做。但因为我和你在一起，我觉得做这件事很安全，而且我知道你会保护我的安全，所以有一点那种不适感是可以的，
discomfort like because that can mean that we're growing yeah no absolutely um i think our brain does that thing doesn't it at the moment it feels discomfort i hate it and stop doing it um it's like you said like when but if you push past it a little bit and you know you actually might find that this is so rewarding and it's such an achievement looking back on it right we've always been there even just doing this i'm like oh there's a bit of that resistant where the brain's like oh do you really want to be doing this but actually now that i'm here it feels great you know i feel like i'm really kind of stretching myself here so and i think that's the key um i think we stop usually before we get to that point don't we as the moment we feel just
因为那可能意味着我们正在成长。是的，绝对是。嗯，我认为我们的大脑会那样做，不是吗？当它感到不适时，我就讨厌它并停止做它。嗯，就像你说的，但如果你稍微克服它，你实际上可能会发现这非常有意义，回首往事时这真是一种成就，对吧？我们一直都在那里，即使只是做这件事，我也在想，哦，有一点抵触情绪，大脑会说，哦，你真的想做这个吗？但实际上，既然我在这里，感觉很棒，你知道，我觉得我真的在扩展自己。我认为这就是关键。嗯，我认为我们通常在到达那个点之前就停止了，不是吗？当我们感到……
come but we're like oh i'm just going to stop now i don't really like it um just because it's and you don't really like it doesn't mean that it's a bad thing actually and I think that's where the wise part of the brain is like when you kind of push through just a little bit if it's within your window of tolerance like you said Marianne and when you look back on it you actually feel wow I really did do that you know I really put myself out there in the podcast and spoke about CBT right and in Jay's instance it's like wow like when was the last time I'd ever actually opened up to someone on my terms. What a great feeling.
……不适时，我们就像，哦，我现在要停下来，我真的不喜欢它。嗯，仅仅因为它让你不喜欢，并不意味着它是一件坏事。实际上，我认为这就是大脑理智部分发挥作用的地方，就像你说的Marian，如果你在你的容忍范围内稍微坚持一下，当你回首往事时，你实际上会觉得，哇，我真的做到了。你知道，我真的在播客中表达了自己，谈论了CBT，对吧？在Jay的例子中，就像，哇，我上次真正按照自己的意愿向某人敞开心扉是什么时候？那种感觉真好。
But again, it's like to say that, well, I don't want to be feeling any kind of discomfort to do that. It's like putting the horse behind the carton, isn't it? We can't really achieve that. So I think that's important to keep in mind to you. That's a really good point, Marian. Yeah, and we've got these things called safety-seeking behaviours, haven't we? So when I'm going to get in my car and go out shortly,
但同样，说“我不想感到任何不适来做这件事”，这就像本末倒置，不是吗？我们无法真正实现这一点。所以我认为记住这一点很重要。Marian，这是一个非常好的观点。是的，我们有被称为“寻求安全行为”的东西，不是吗？所以当我一会儿要上车出去时，
I'm going to put my seatbelt on, and that's an adaptive safety-seeking behaviour. But if I'm standing in a shop and I'm feeling a bit hot and flustered and I think, oh, I'd better get my water out my bad. Oh, oh, God, that's not helping. I'll blot, you know, I'll vent my top a bit, try and get a bit there. But, oh, no, I'm not going to cope with all this noise
我会系好安全带，这是一种适应性的寻求安全行为。但如果我站在商店里，感到有点热和慌乱，我想，哦，我最好从包里拿出水。哦，天哪，那没用。我会擦擦汗，你知道，我会扇扇衣服，试着凉快一点。但是，哦，不，我无法应对所有这些噪音，
and it's too much. And I leave the shop. And then I get outside and I go, thank God I did that because I never would have coped. Actually, I probably, in different circumstances, with enough resources would have coped sufficiently to buy my bread and my milk. But I've almost invalidated myself, I've drafted and pulled in that safety-seeking behaviour, which has made me feel like that saved me, because then I've got outside
这太过了。然后我离开了商店。然后我到了外面，我说，谢天谢地我那样做了，因为我永远无法应对。实际上，在不同的情况下，如果有足够的资源，我可能足以应对去买面包和牛奶。但我几乎否定了自己，我采取并使用了那种寻求安全行为，这让我觉得它救了我，因为然后我到了外面，
and my kind of distress levels have dropped, okay? But I guess often when I'm thinking with clients, I think about actually how much longer would it have needed until you naturally plateaued anyway? and then you did cope. And often what we find is that people will put in these safety-seeking behaviours just at the point when they were going to ride it out anyway. And then they begin to think, well, I always need that. And I know that CBT can help people to focus in on their safety-seeking behaviours
我的那种痛苦程度下降了，好吗？但我猜通常当我和客户一起思考时，我会想，实际上你还需要多久才能自然地达到平稳状态？然后你确实应对过来了。我们经常发现，人们会在他们本来就要挺过去的时候采取这些寻求安全行为。然后他们开始认为，好吧，我总是需要那个。我知道CBT可以帮助人们专注于他们的寻求安全行为，
and think about which ones are adaptive actually make really good sense and which ones maybe we can just maybe implement a little bit later or use a little bit less or think about using a different one that gets us to stay in, that situation so that we can have that incredible feeling of mastery and satisfaction that comes when a client says to you, oh my God, I did it. I felt anxious, but I stayed. And then I had this really great chat with someone and it went like really, and you know, you almost see someone come back online. And once you've almost taken control of that beast and, you know, you've shown it. Actually, I'm not having a panic. I'm not doing that. I've ridden it out. It almost
并思考哪些是适应性的，实际上非常有意义，哪些是我们也许可以稍后再实施，或者少用一点，或者考虑使用不同的方法，让我们留在那种情况下，这样我们就能获得那种令人难以置信的掌控感和满足感，当客户对你说，天哪，我做到了。我感到焦虑，但我留下来了。然后我和某人进行了一次非常好的交谈，进展非常顺利，你知道，你几乎看到某人恢复了状态。一旦你几乎控制了那只野兽，你知道，你已经向它展示了。实际上，我没有恐慌。我没有那样做。我已经挺过来了。它几乎
kind of inoculates or kind of kills off the panic it can't get you in the same way absolutely I think recognising the difference between adaptive and safety-seeking behaviour is really important I think especially when working with sort of if someone's autistic and then naturally needing to self-soothe in social situations because it makes them overwhelmed that's an adaptive behaviour because that's kind of helping them deal with that situation in that moment so that they can engage in day-to-day life and do their things however that same behavior can be a safety-seeking thing when they don't go out at all and they're afraid and worried about judgment so if i was to even bring up an example of
……接种了疫苗，或者说消除了恐慌，它不能再以同样的方式影响你了。绝对的。我认为认识到适应性行为和寻求安全行为之间的区别非常重要。我认为特别是在与自闭症患者合作时，他们自然需要在社交场合自我安抚，因为这让他们感到不知所措，这是一种适应性行为，因为这在当下帮助他们应对那种情况，以便他们能够参与日常生活并做他们的事情。然而，当他们根本不出门，并且害怕和担心被评判时，同样的这种行为可能就是一种寻求安全行为。所以如果我要举一个例子，
working with someone a made-up client if they're going to go out somewhere and they're thinking i'm going to be so overwhelmed i don't even want to bother going out actually what are some of the adaptive adaptive strategies that you've got there you know is it kind of headphones. What else do you do? Is there anything that you can kind of, anyone you can go with? So that way, when they put these resources in place, they're still able to go to that situation. And despite having these resources to help ride the wave, actually to put themselves out there like that and to come back and say, actually, I went and did it. And I really enjoyed myself. Yeah, I had a minute or two. I went out for a break, got some fresh air,
与某人合作，一个虚构的客户，如果他们要出去某个地方，他们想“我会感到非常不知所措，我甚至不想费心出去”，实际上，你有什么适应性的策略吗？你知道，是耳机吗？你还做什么？有什么你可以做的吗？有人可以陪你吗？这样，当他们落实这些资源时，他们仍然能够去那个情况。尽管有这些资源来帮助驾驭波浪，实际上他们还是把自己置身于那种情况，回来并说，实际上，我去了并做了。我真的很享受。是的，我有一两分钟的时间。我出去休息了一下，呼吸了新鲜空气，
put my headphones on. Actually, I went back in and I, you know, got down on the dance floor and had a really good time and it was on my terms. That's what we want to see more of. Safety-seeking behaviours. What we tend to find out is they might feel like, oh, this is really helpful in the moment, but it might not be on your terms in the long run. And that can be for any situation. So when you're going to the supermarket and you're overwhelmed and you're like, I'm going to leave now. It might feel like it's on your terms in that moment. But then in the long run, the next time you think about the supermarket, you might think, oh, let me just go with someone or, you know what, let me just order online.
戴上了耳机。实际上，我回去了，你知道，在舞池里跳舞，玩得很开心，而且是按照我自己的意愿。这就是我们想看到的更多东西。寻求安全行为。我们倾向于发现，它们在当下可能感觉“哦，这真的很有帮助”，但从长远来看，这可能不是按照你的意愿。这适用于任何情况。所以当你去超市感到不知所措时，你会想“我现在要离开”。这在当下可能感觉是按照你的意愿。但从长远来看，下次你想到超市时，你可能会想“哦，让我和某人一起去吧”或者“你知道吗，让我直接在线订购吧”。
It kind of almost build over time, don't it? And then it becomes this, you know, your life becomes very shut off and, you know, very small. But by recognizing that and actually thinking, you know what, if I can't stay in the supermarket for 10 minutes, let me try for five minutes, that's an achievement. If you leave the moment, you know, the anxiety kicks off. And then you might realize that actually, you know, the distress kind of, like you said, kind of starts plateauing a little bit. And that is scientifically proven. So CBT is based on empiricism.
它几乎随着时间的推移而建立，不是吗？然后它变成了这样，你知道，你的生活变得非常封闭，你知道，非常狭小。但通过认识到这一点，实际上思考，“你知道吗，如果我不能在超市待10分钟，让我尝试5分钟”，那也是一种成就。如果你在焦虑开始的那一刻离开。然后你可能会意识到，实际上，你知道，痛苦程度，就像你说的，开始有点平稳了。这是经过科学证明的。所以CBT是基于经验主义的。
So it's just a fancy term that basically means it's based on science, really. We're not, you know, we're not sort of spewing pop psychology or, you know, it's not based on nothing. It's based on real evidence. And it's well known that once your anxiety kicks off, if people kind of stay in the situation, it doesn't sustain it can't go on forever it has to come down and people like you said marion don't really just as they're about to kind of I guess desensitize or habituate or you know just as it about to plateau they don't really get there they kind of withdraw pull out before then and that is a safety behavior absolutely just before we finish sana who might not be a good candidate for cb
所以这只是一个花哨的术语，基本上意味着它确实是基于科学的。我们不是，你知道，我们不是在喷洒流行心理学，或者，你知道，它不是基于虚无。它是基于真实的证据。众所周知，一旦你的焦虑开始，如果人们坚持留在那种情况下，它不会持续，它不可能永远持续下去，它必须下降。人们，就像你说的Marian，并没有真正地，就在他们即将，我猜，脱敏或习惯化，或者，你知道，就在它即将平稳时，他们并没有真正到达那里，他们在之前就撤退、退出了，那是一种安全行为。绝对的。在我们结束之前，Sana，谁可能不是CBT的合适人选，
or what kind of conditions might not be a first choice for CBT? Yeah, so I think it depends. So I'll bring on like a few different factors. Because CBT can be quite structured, so usually you set an agenda and then typically that involves a bit of a check-in, how did you get on with the between-session exercises, looking at tools, and then setting, you know, what are you going to look at? if people don't really connect with that kind of structure, then it might not be for them.
或者什么样的条件可能不是CBT的首选？是的，所以我认为这取决于。所以我将提出几个不同的因素。因为CBT可能非常结构化，所以通常你会设定一个议程，然后通常这涉及一点检查，你在会话间的练习做得怎么样，查看工具，然后设定，你知道，你要看什么？如果人们真的不适应那种结构，那么它可能不适合他们。
And that's okay. You know, there are other approaches. It's not that therapy's failed you. It's just, it's not your cup of tea. That's completely fine. Another thing I wanted to bring up is if there were a lot of life stresses, and what I mean by that is I'm not saying that, you know, you shouldn't go to therapy. There's so much going on.
那没关系。你知道，还有其他方法。并不是治疗让你失败了。只是，它不是你的菜。这完全没问题。我想提出的另一件事是，如果有很多生活压力，我的意思是，我不是说，你知道，你不应该去接受治疗。有很多事情正在发生。
But if there were a lot of social stresses, if you're having like housing issues, financial difficulties, and that takes precedent over kind of your anxiety disorders or low mood, then perhaps I always say the kindest thing to do is look at how we can best support you on that. And it might not be CBT therapy, it might be something else. Another thing I wanted to mention, which I want to show a bit of a cycle to demonstrate this, Rocheska and de Clemente created this cycle for health-related behaviours and changes when it comes to that. So typically we want CBT is most effective when people are in that preparation stage or the action stage and it can really, we can really then bolster them to be able to look at making those changes and sustaining them and preventing relapse. However, on some occasions, clients might be quite unsure, you know, they might not be sure whether they're ready for that change.
但如果有很多社会压力，如果你有住房问题、经济困难，而这优先于你的焦虑症或情绪低落，那么也许我总是说最友善的做法是看看我们如何能最好地支持你。那可能不是CBT治疗，可能是其他东西。我想提到的另一件事，我想展示一个周期来证明这一点，Rocheska和de Clemente为健康相关的行为和变化创造了这个周期。所以通常我们希望CBT在人们处于准备阶段或行动阶段时最有效，然后我们可以真正地支持他们，使他们能够着眼于做出这些改变并维持它们，防止复发。然而，在某些情况下，客户可能非常不确定，你知道，他们可能不确定他们是否准备好做出那种改变。
the more sort of figuring out what's going on with them and for that that would require a different approach I think so that's why I you know I always show this cycle you know kind of where are you at in this sort of cycle you know are you still thinking that there's a problem but you're not quite ready to change but you want to talk about it that's not necessarily CBT but there is another approach for that like counselling but if you really kind of want to create that change you're ready for that but you're sort of wanting that extra bit of support then absolutely, you know, we can work together. Absolutely. Super, too.
更多的是弄清楚他们身上发生了什么，对于这一点，那将需要一种不同的方法。所以我认为这就是为什么我，你知道，我总是展示这个周期，你知道，你在这种周期中处于什么位置，你知道，你是否仍然认为有一个问题，但你还没有准备好改变，但你想谈谈它？那不一定是CBT，但有另一种方法，比如咨询。但如果你真的想创造那种改变，你准备好了，但你想要那种额外的支持，那么绝对，你知道，我们可以一起工作。绝对的。太棒了。
Thank you so much for your time today. You're going to be joining us for another episode where we think about how someone can train as a CBT therapist if they wanted to or what a career in CBT might look like and what next steps are possible from that as well. So if you've enjoyed listening to me and Sahana, please do drop some Sahana love into the comments. And yeah, we'll be back along very soon with the second episode.
非常感谢你今天的时间。你将加入我们的下一集，我们将思考如果有人想成为一名CBT治疗师，他们该如何培训，或者CBT的职业生涯可能是什么样的，以及从中可能采取的下一步措施。所以如果你喜欢听我和Sahana的谈话，请在评论中留下一些对Sahana的爱。是的，我们很快会带着第二集回来。
Thank you so much for your time today. Thank you. Thank you so much. It's been nice talking about CBT in this context. I appreciate you having me. Oh, you're so welcome. Thank you so much. Thank you so much for watching and of course for my guest, Sahana, in her time talking with us about what CBT is. If you have found it helpful, please do drop a comment, drop a like. Consider subscribing to the channel if you'd like to see more from me, especially if you'd like to see more from Sahana because she's back along next week. to. If you're watching this video because you would like to consider accessing therapy, please do consider checking out the Talking Heads book. It's your guide to help you to find a qualified
非常感谢你今天的时间。谢谢。非常感谢。在这个背景下谈论CBT很高兴。我很感激你邀请我。哦，不客气。非常感谢。非常感谢大家的观看，当然还有我的嘉宾Sahana，感谢她花时间与我们谈论什么是CBT。如果你觉得有帮助，请留下评论，点个赞。如果你想看到我更多的内容，请考虑订阅该频道，特别是如果你想看到更多Sahana的内容，因为她下周会回来。如果你观看这个视频是因为你想考虑接受治疗，请考虑查看《Talking Heads》这本书。它是你寻找合格的指南，
regulated therapist in the UK and it's a book that I wrote with my colleague Dr Tara. Of course, like any of my books, any of my resources, there are links in the description and in the show notes. Come and grab your free Psychology Success Guide on my website, www. aspiring hyphen psychologist.com.com.uk. Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications, and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful, and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills.
在英国受监管的治疗师，这是我和我的同事Tara博士一起写的一本书。当然，像我所有的书、我所有的资源一样，描述和节目说明中有链接。来我的网站www.aspiringhyphenpsychologist.com.com.uk获取你的免费心理学成功指南。嗨，我叫Emily。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家集体》这本书来帮助自己为第一轮博士申请做准备，我很高兴我买了。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，它让我对自己旅程和技能有很多反思。
It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get on to the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它也有助于从长远角度看待问题，并提醒我，如果我今年没有考上博士，那也没关系。然而，我认为这本书最意想不到的乐趣是每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心。每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力真是一种乐趣。我几乎不舍得读完。此集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。